we live as part of a system and the
things that have been supporting the
system since you and i have been alive
are unlikely to continue for too much
longer and so we're going to have to
change how we get our evolutionary
neurotransmitters the emotional states
of our ancestors probably with using
less energy and materials than we do
today
what i find particularly interesting
about your work is that you're looking
at energy you're also looking at human
flourishing you're also looking at
economics you're looking at the past the
present the future
given the fact that many of the people
listening won't be familiar with your
worldview and your work
what is important in the story of how we
got here so what do we need to know
about our history before we can assess
where we're at at the moment
it's a big question uh i think uh we
live in a culture that focuses on
technology and human ingenuity and money
as the things that describe
our wealth and our future trajectory and
i think
culturally educationally we
misunderstand or
fail to recognize
the importance of ecology and energy to
our lives
and
we live as part of a system so for the
last 20 years i've tried to connect the
dots
of how the pieces of the human ecosystem
fit together
you mentioned economy which is
technology and materials and energy and
human ingenuity there's also
the environment and climate change and
other species and biodiversity and
ecosystem health there's also
anthropology and neuroscience which i
know you spend a lot of time on who we
are as evolved
animals have arrived here after 300 000
years
but
because our our brains and our bodies
were shaped from the past and we are
biological organisms
and energy is the central currency in
nature animals were the first investors
and we just think of investing money but
everything we do
requires energy every single thing that
ends up in a good or service that
contributes to gdp or gross domestic
product are the size of our economy
requires energy
to invent to mine the materials for it
to create to distribute to operate to
maintain to fix and to dispose of
without energy all of our technology
would just be sculptures and so without
energy our cities would be museums
and this makes sense right except
we assume that we will have the energy
we have now uh indefinitely and that's
where the risk comes in and i think um
what's happening in ukraine and russia
right now
is causing people to become a little bit
more aware of oh my god we're really
dependent on energy well in this case
germany and europe
are really recognizing what's what's
happening so long story short
we live as part of a system
and the
things that have been supporting the
system since you and i have been alive
are unlikely to continue for too much
longer and so we're going to have to
change how we get our evolutionary
neurotransmitters the the emotional
states of our ancestors probably with
using less
energy and materials
than we do today
why are things going to have to change
in future
ah
okay so let's talk a little bit about
energy
properties and energy quality so
there are lots of different forms of
energy
and
we use
predominantly fossil energy which we are
pulling out of the ground
10 million times faster
than it was trickle charged by daily
photosynthesis of the sun so the master
resource
in the global economy now is is crude
oil and from that come diesel fuel and
gasoline and kerosene and jet fuel and
bunker fuel and six thousand other
plastic precursors
oil is the master resource
oil is found where there were ancient
oceans and it so happens that you and i
live in a country where a lot of ancient
oceans were and so america has used
more oil in the last 20 years in the
last 50 years since the dawn of time
than any other country let me tell you
how powerful oil is
even for a super fit guy like you chris
um
and and i uh i have an emotional memory
of when we had dinner in austin a few
weeks ago
the happiness on your face when you
realize that there were larger plates
and you could pile more food on your
plate you had you looked like a kid on
christmas morning when you figured you
could put more food on your plate
but but the average american today um
uses 57 barrel of oil equivalents of
crude oil
natural gas and and coal if we convert
those things into oil
one barrel of oil
has 5.7 million british thermal units
worth of energy if you translate that
into work potential
it's 1
700 kilowatt hours worth of work
and you
or i in one day could generate around
0.6 kilowatt hours of work you're pretty
fit so you might be able to do 0.8 or 1
maybe
but on average a human working a 8-hour
day
generates around six tenths of a
kilowatt hour of work meaning
a barrel of oil which we pay a hundred
dollars for
can displace
four and a half years of yours or my
physical labor
a gallon of gasoline is like two months
of our work
so we are using
as a global culture 100 billion
barrel of oil equivalents of coal oil
and natural gas every year
so if each of those is worth four and a
half years of human labor
we're adding roughly the equivalent of
500 billion
human worker equivalents to the real
five billion human worker equivalents
we're paying pennies on the dollar for
this
because what we're doing is all our
economic system is doing is paying for
the cost of extraction
how much does it cost us to go into the
permian basin and pull that ancient
sunlight out and add it to our economies
that's what the economists look at we're
not paying for the tens of millions of
years of creation nor of the pollution
like climate change and ocean
acidification
so why is this a problem because this
stuff
we're treating it culturally as if it
were interest but the reality is we're
drawing down the principle as i said 10
million times
faster than it was sequestered
so
what we did in the united states is we
used the beverly hillbillies oil the
really
high quality easy to access oil first
then we went to the north slope of
alaska which isn't even contiguous to us
but it's part of our country
and got that oil then we went into the
gulf of mexico and went under the ocean
to access oil
now in the last 10 years we've had the
shale oil revolution which is we drill
down and have these horizontal uh
fracturing
technology that
sucks it out really fast but it depletes
really fast so one of these
new uh
horizontal um
shale wells will deplete at 80 percent
in the first 18 months so we need to
drill again to get more so what's
happening now is we've reached the
source rock the the formations in our
country
where the oil originated all the oil
that we've had for the last 50 60 70
years originated there there's nothing
left after that
so let me tell you this fact and this is
something that hardly anyone pays
attention to
because why because
we can get plenty of energy today it's a
little more costly but there's still
plenty available
if we were to stop drilling
for environmental reasons for lack of
capital for political reasons for any
reason at all
our oil production in the united states
which is around 12 million barrels a day
right now and we consume 20 million by
the way so we're still importing a good
deal of what we consume
if we stop drilling our oil production
would drop by 40
the first year and by like 25 the second
year and 20 percent the third year and
that's because all the oil wells that
we've drilled in the past
are depleting rapidly and a higher and
higher percentage of our oil production
is this tight oil the shale oil that
depletes rapidly so we're like this red
queen alice in wonderland scenario where
we have to run faster and faster just to
stay in place
and so the reason this is a problem is
oil is the master resource and it
underpins everything in globalization
our transportation global supply chains
the complexity of our system
and and the other aspect of energy that
we don't quite understand is people say
oh well
if oil is running out
we'll just go to solar and wind
and solar and wind are viable they're
robust they're mature
they're not
terribly expensive
but
first of all they are electricity
okay so solar wind geothermal all those
things produce
electricity and electricity is only
around 21 percent of global energy use
the rest is heat and liquid fuels and
other things like and transportation
things like that
the other challenge with with renewables
is is that they're they're intermittent
so we have to either couple them with
something like natural gas which we can
turn on right away when when there's a
power demand you live in texas you know
what's happening right now this week
people are you can't have everything
running and everything growing
there are limits uh and if you have a
heat wave like you do right now and it's
really still and the wind isn't blowing
you could have five times as much wind
installed as you do today and it's still
not going to give you power so you have
to have
natural gas or something like that as a
complement or batteries or
or use less
and the used last part is not in our
political conversation
but it's coming uh in my opinion and the
sooner that
individual people start changing their
perception of energy services and
what does it really mean
to live a good life do i need all this
energy and stuff the more pilots and
examples
will have of of different cultural paths
so you're a um
you're a well i don't even know that you
are you just look like you are a
bodybuilder and a weightlifter so you
think you probably think about calories
and things like that so the average
american consumes via our mouth around 2
000 calories kilocalories a day
we actually consume more than that
because we waste a lot so it's like 3
000 but in our bodies
our bodies internally
eat consume 2 000 calories a day but the
average american consumes
210
000 kilocalories a day worth of energy
in
if you take the 330 million people in
america and then you divide that into
all of the energy that we use the coal
the oil the natural gas the solar the
wind the nuclear
it works out to about every
human living in america consumes 210 000
kilocalories a day
100 times
more
than our bodies need
for physical metabolism now some we need
probably more than that we need a roofer
of our heads we need food we need uh
hospitals and things like that but do we
need a hundred to one so europe uh uses
50 to one 50 times more than their
bodies need but the united states uses
around four times the global average why
determines of energy
well
we first of all happened to be born in a
country that was blessed with a geology
of having lots of fossil hydrocarbons
here
secondly we had the most powerful
country in the world
the last century and so we were able to
do during various
bretton woods
plaza accords the international
financial order is is revolves around
the u.s dollar so the us dollar receives
the seniority or the economic benefit
from being the world's reserve currency
because other countries need the same
things that we do but they have to
buy them because they're denominated in
u.s dollars so it's this huge
international economic
tailwinds for the united states because
we have 85 percent of our own energy
whereas europe is is like a tiny
fraction of that japan has hardly any of
their own energy
so we have this energy um bounty that uh
is the foundation of our economies and
we have the world's reserve currency and
the largest most trusted uh central bank
but these things are not uh
they're not uh uh you know our
our god-given right and they don't
naturally um persist for centuries uh i
think in the next decade
a lot more people are going to
understand how central energy is
to our lives
so
to kind of try and
conclude everything there
the access that we've had specifically
to oil
that has been low hanging fruit for the
last 100 years 150 years something like
that
the access that we've had there has
meant that getting energy has been
relatively easy
and it's also been relatively
cheap
compared with how much how harder it's
going to be we haven't offset the cost
of the generation of that energy in the
past which was sun
for 10 million years or whatever it is
and
we also haven't offset much of the
externalities that come out the side of
using that energy
one of the problems that we're going to
have as we look forward is we have set
ourselves a civilization a particular
barometer a
status of energy usage which you could
see as convenience or a level of comfort
or a level of convenience in life um
that is the level that we like to be at
and as we continue to move forward if
energy becomes more difficult for us to
extract and use and yet we need to
continue at the same degree of
convenience comfort
and lifestyle that we have at the moment
you're going to begin with an imbalance
there the demand is going to stay the
same but the supply is going to drop
that therefore means that there is going
to be an increasing further around
getting energy which means that we need
to either
increase the supply or decrease the
demand in order to level things out how
close am i there
pretty darn close good good it's only
taken me it's only taken me a couple of
weeks after going for dinner with you so
first question nuclear why can't we use
nuclear
nuclear is a strange thing it's like
what everyone always immediately asks
well yeah what about nuclear okay so
here's here's a quick review of nuclear
like solar and wind it is electricity
so
only 20 percent of our our global
current situation
is electric now we could change more
things to electric and we probably
should
but if all of a sudden we miraculously
had 10 times as much nuclear power today
it still wouldn't solve some of these
problems because oil is a declining
liquid fuel that's step number one or
point number one point number two
is just like solar and wind have
different uh
production profiles
um that are different than the human
demand if you look at texas
when the most energy is used in the late
afternoons because people are coming
home and they have air conditioning on
and then the middle of the night there's
a there's a trough because people are
sleeping
so what the perfect energy source is
like natural gas because you can turn it
on when you need it and you can turn it
off when you don't need it nuclear you
can't really turn off it's just always
on
and it's flat
so nuclear plus natural gas good
combination solar and wind plus natural
gas good combination nuclear alone
can't
meet the the variability of human energy
use so far
point number two point number three
is it takes a lot of capital and a lot
of time and a lot of complexity to build
out nuclear
and some of the issues that i'm talking
about are coming this decade uh we
haven't talked about money yet i don't
know if you want to but that's a central
part of this story
so there's there's a long time lag on
nuclear
point number four we don't have the
uranium for nuclear to extend probably
beyond six or seven decades
um i mean there
uranium is much more abundant than high
quality oil at this point but it's also
not infinite
point number five would be
the cost of nuclear um
the negative environmental costs are
always at the tail end and it's true
that i think people have overreacted to
chernobyl and fukushima
and the cancer risks there
but it's because we've had this cohesive
world system that's held together and we
have 450 odd nuclear plants in the world
what if
there was some event that caused a
breakdown in social complexity and an
inability to
maintain these nuclear plants
the environmental cost would then be
discovered so we have to kind of
maintain these things in
perpetuity for there not to be some
meltdown things so those are the few
things but i do personally feel probably
we're going to need nuclear a lot more
nuclear as part of the mix going forward
this century but it's not a direct one
for one solution to these problems oh
here's another point chris
and this gets into the anthropology part
of of the discussion but if humans today
found a
too cheap to meter energy source
a
nominal view of that would be oh my gosh
problem solved but our economic system
is one that consumes and grows and if we
had something that was unbelievably
cheap
suddenly oil would no longer be a
problem energy would not be a problem
but our oceans and our biosphere and the
number of other species that are
declining and all these other things
that are
externalities as you say of the human
system would get far worse
so even a cheap alternative to our
situation
doesn't solve those issues
what about if we were to find more oil
and coal and natural gas outside of
america how close are we to being able
to
dig down to the bottom of the pacific
and there's a ton there i don't know but
i'd heard i remember reading a long time
ago about how
there is way more uh fossil fuel
uh
opportunity out there than we've tapped
into so far and it's a case of scouting
more and we've only scratched the
surface in terms of the allowance that
we could dig into
there's a lot of research in this we
have far more than scratched the surface
every single year we find less and less
oil and oil discoveries and you have to
discover oil before you produce it
peaked 50 years ago and have been in a
steep decline since then
there is a lot of oil um outside of the
borders of the usa but let's for the for
the moment let's set aside geopolitics
because i think once the pie starts to
shrink that turns us into a phase shift
of different human behavior
but for instance
if you draw a 600 mile
triangle around
jeddah saudi arabia into iran
approximately 60 of the world's
remaining oil reserves are in that 600
mile triangle
so there's lots of oil left in the world
the issue is
partially where it's
where it's located
and that would explain why we have those
military bases in the middle east
but the other issue is one of flow rate
so venezuela has something called the
orinoco sands and
alberta canada has the tar sands tar
sands are like
uncompleted oil that is basically
oily sand that you have to apply more
energy and heat to to turn it into
usable oil
so
that's a huge complex rube goldberg
machine process up there and we can get
oil out of that but it's the flow rate
of how quickly it gets out
so
the world uses 95 million barrels a day
of oil today
um
certainly there's enough for 50 60
million barrels a day for many decades
um
but the the the total amount the total
pool
is not infinite um i i would argue that
we've used about half
how do you know where the oil is
what's left how much is left are there
any hopes that there could be oil
outside of the places that we've already
done surveys
there almost certainly is oil left
in places that we haven't discovered yet
including the arctic
uh which once the glaciers uh melt
people will be accessing
uh the arctic shelf to to access oil
there are many many different geological
surveys that look at
reserves that are available how many
years are left at a certain price
and those
you know range from
10 years to 30 years and then they
expect that we will
discover some in the future and that
number is always changing
um
so the issue really isn't
that we're running out of oil we were
running out of oil from when the first
well was drilled in 1859.
the issue is that we're running out of
enough oil at an affordable price to
maintain economic growth
and once we can't
continue to grow our economies
and the economic growth now is at a
50-year low economic growth for for our
country peaked in the early 1970s and
we've grown the whole time since then
but we've grown at lower amounts every
year
once we
aren't able to grow
we face this
metaphorical or not so metaphorical
musical chair situation because of the
amount of monetary claims
on real resources so money is created by
commercial banks making loans
without any reference to how much oil or
environmental services or natural
resources or materials exist
and so we keep growing our monetary
claims
on our underlying physical reality and
every time you spend a dollar from your
wallet or from your bank
you spend it on something that requires
energy so we keep growing the amount of
monetary claims we have when our energy
is actually slowly inexorably declining
so that's the thing that i'm worried
about in the next decade is the delta
between those two trends
and you can see the central bankers of
the world are just running around like
an ants nest just got kicked they don't
really have a strategy for this
because they want to uh continue to grow
the economies and yet at the same time
they don't want inflation and they can
print money but they can't print energy
they can only make the rules so we can
extract energy faster
is that what you mean by natural capital
natural capital is our soil it's our
forests it's our ecosystems it is also
the resources under the ground that we
are mining at at very fast rates copper
water sand oil yes
right
and and if you extend the boundary of
your concern
or your ethics
natural capital would also include
termites and mongoose and elk and lions
and geese etc
[Music]
is money
fundamentally
energy
in in one way then is money just a way
of trading energy because ultimately
everything comes down to it that nothing
can be produced without it
money is is a claim on energy
and debt is a claim on future energy so
when a country when a person
or a country
runs into financial difficulties and
they can't afford what they want or need
they will borrow money
to do that
and
that borrowing
is an increase in the world's future
claims
on energy and so we have the the
challenge we're going to have in coming
decades
is we have all these financial claims
on a dwindling pool of of energy and
resources and the ultimate answer and we
won't choose this answer until we have
to
is we're gonna have to use less
and that doesn't have to be a disaster
and all of my work is preparing
individuals and cultures and communities
and maybe policies
for
that inevitable moment
i mean look chris
most people know that the current
economic system is not really working
for them there's this intuitive
recognition that all this energy and
stuff isn't really making us
happy and healthy and you've explored
some of these things on on your show
after basic needs are met the best
things in life are free
and
our economic system is geared toward
measuring our success measuring our
progress
by the size of our energy use gdp is
really just a measure for how much stuff
we burn in the world because how do you
mean that
every single product that ends up in the
world economic system that's counted as
a good or service started somewhere on
the planet with a small fire
in some factory there was energy
underpinning it all
why is there this embedded growth
obligation
ah
well one could argue from an
evolutionary sense that animals um
when they're young they need more
calories to grow
um and humans too we when we're 10 years
old when we're 12 years old we're eating
we want to grow but then we reach 20
something and we stop growing our
economic system is different because
we've self-organized around this bolus
of fossil sunlight
that our ancestors not too long ago knew
where their wealth came from
it came from the sun and the hydrologic
cycles and the soil and the work of
their mussels and their animals to
create things a blacksmith and
a forester and a baker and a craftsman
and we would use the products of the
forest and and and such to build an
economy and then
we basically all these fossil workers
came out of the ground and were added to
our economies
and we lost that connection with the
natural world defining our limits and
our aspirations and we started to create
economic rules that all this giant
increase
in average human uh consumption per
capita and a lot more people per capita
a lot more capital we started to
attribute that to human cleverness and
ingenuity
and so we then started to build an
economic system that
lauded growth as the answer i mean gdp
when it was first created was around
world war
ii
and it wasn't meant to be a goal it was
just created as a scorecard of how much
stuff we were creating
but then the money thing got involved
and
i don't know how much you know about how
money is created but 95 of our money is
created at commercial banks when they
make a loan
they are not loaning out existing
capital they are creating money
um
as long as there is a credit worthy
borrower but what they're not creating
is the interest on the loan
so right there there's an embedded
growth obligation in our system
i can break this down in a short example
say that you go into the bank of austin
and you have a cool business idea and
they like you and you have a credit
worthy
personality and history and they are in
good standing with the federal reserve
chris here's a million dollars at that
point they put a million dollars into
your account at the bank
and simul that that's your asset and
simultaneously they put chris owes us a
million dollars on their asset li ledger
so in the world nothing has happened you
both have a million and you owe a
million and they both gave a million and
they are owed a million
but two other things
happened that people don't often talk
about number one is there's a million
dollars more of purchasing power in our
world in our economic system that is a
claim
on future energy and resources you could
invest that in a business or you could
just take a cruise or buy a yacht to go
tool around lake austin or whatever you
want but it's all a potential future
claim on energy and resources the second
thing is they did not create the
interest for you so during
your job or whatever you do
you have to eventually pay them back the
million dollars and every year in the
meantime you have to pay the interest
uh 50 grand or whatever the percentage
rate on that is so if you add that up
globally
there is an imperative that we have to
grow to maintain prior financial claims
simultaneously that growth
it draws down our natural capital
and creates environmental externalities
that you pointed out before
pretty much are not included in our
prices
didn't i see you explain about how
certain countries are including
prostitution and drug sales in their gdp
in an effort to
keep the debt
to
capital ratio correct
yes
countries in europe in order to maintain
their standing with the european central
bank where the european central bank
still allows them to borrow
they can only borrow if their debt to
gdp is under a certain threshold and so
as they have more and more debt
their gdp isn't growing enough to stay
under that threshold so they're adding
new things into the definition of gdp
like prostitution and drugs
what were previously illicit drug sales
now uh that that's a tiny example but it
also
gives us a glimpse
of
what are the things that we really care
about because there's a lot of things
that you and i do in our lives possibly
are our most favorite things
that aren't included in gdp making love
with your partner going for a walk in
the woods playing with your dogs none of
those things are included in gdp
so this this question of
how can we get our evolutionary
emotional states of our ancestors
with using less energy and materials
in other words what is an economy for
this is like front and center
going to start to be a real question
um but yeah i think europe is going to
face these issues before we do um
already because there were
cracks in the mortar before russia and
ukraine but now definitely because of
russia and ukraine and and the fact that
germany is a manufacturing hub they
import resources from other countries
and then they have technology and they
make high quality stuff
but russia is a resource hub they have
the largest energy reserves in the world
pretty much and you could argue saudi
arabia but russia has a lot of natural
resources and so
that is the the eyes are being opened
for the disparity between a monetary
representation of reality and a
biophysical representation of reality
like energy and materials materials is
not something that we've talked about
but real quickly
when we create a product there's three
things that are required there's the
technology of how to combine things and
how to package it there's the energy and
there's the materials
the materials could be copper or
aluminum or sand or lithium or any of
these things but in the last century
we've grown our material footprint
at 2.8 a year which is about what we've
grown our economy at
so
pretty much if we double the size of our
economy we're going to double the size
of our
need for materials and nearly double the
size of our energy requirement
i'm going to try and summarize i think
where we've got to now
so
one of the issues that we have is that
humans are
over using energy
to not get a return in terms of
flourishing or happiness now that's not
to say that
the air conditioning's just come on it's
105 degrees outside i like the fact that
we've got air conditioning but
did i need to have my tv on while i
looked at my phone last night did i need
the bluetooth speaker so
the question is that if
anything that we want to do
with our lives requires energy that can
be represented as money or whatever but
if anything that we do with our lives
is it requires energy at the same time
as a lot of people in the world
feel like there's something wrong feel
like the current
cultural
and uh political and
local social
world is not giving them a sense of
nourishment in the way that they want it
to
yet they are using
100 000 times or a thousand times a
hundred times more than 100 times more a
hundred times more energy than they
actually need in order to survive maybe
you could probably knock that down to 50
because yeah the hospital visit that you
go once per year the air conditioning
that stops you from dying you know the
water that you need to blah blah blah
blah blah the point being that we are
way way way um over leveraged in terms
of
how much energy we are using to give
ourselves a life that for many people
they don't feel fully fulfilled with
the disparity between those two things
kind of again is like the supply and
demand thing but this time we're talking
about the um supply or the demand that
we need for energy and the supply in
terms of how much happiness that that
energy actually gives us there is an
imbalance there and what you're
suggesting is that by hook or by crook
at some point in the future the energy
is going to slow down because our access
to the low hanging fruit is going to
limit that
there is only one outcome unless we find
some other form of energy that is able
to supplant that uh
we're going to have to have our
energy uses constrained
and given that fact
front loading an idea around what do we
actually want to do with our lives what
is it that makes us happy how can we use
energy and the most
flourishing efficient way
would be a good model to get into our
heads right now
it's no wonder you have a very popular
podcast you've summarized it quite
nicely and as far as the hook or the
crook we are not going to voluntarily
choose this look at what's happening
right now with biden he's flying to
saudi arabia fist bumping the the prince
because we want saudi arabia to
boost their oil production because
we want lower oil prices so people can
continue to consume and have the
convenience
that they have at the same time
president biden is very worried about
climate change so he wants us to use
less fossil fuels
but the momentum the metabolism of our
civilization is such that we will use
everything
that we can
and we will even create rule changes to
access more until we can't it's the
until we can't moment that i'm trying to
create a social discourse around and
it's exactly what you said i think the
first step is to remove the energy
blinders to actually have energy
appreciation oh my god look at the
amount of things in my
house there's 60 items that draw in
energy all the time and i take it for
granted because
i pay a 150 a month for my electricity
bill or whatever that's peanuts that's
nothing it's always been available but
we from a metabolic standpoint are
living material lives richer than kings
and queens of old just the average among
us
and the reason that we're not having
this conversation is because it's always
been there and when there's a short-term
crisis like in the 1970s or the
financial crisis in 2009 or covid
is we
we paper it over with money
and there's a little bit of an acute
feeling of discomfort but then it goes
away
but in the not too distant future we
won't be able to increase oil production
no matter how much we drill and it's not
like the energy is going away it's just
the amount
of
the really cheap stuff is going away to
power our current expectations
so you some did quite well chris
how much should energy cost how much
should a barrel of oil cost if you were
to
um
absorb in
the millions of years of sunlight and
all of the externalities have you ever
run that figure
there are people we'll let's first talk
about coal um coal cost around uh five
cents a kilowatt hour and there are
people that have looked at the
environmental externalities and if you
include all the negative
pricings it should be over 20 cents so
400 percent higher than it is
but you know where do you draw the
boundaries on that because some of the
externalities are things that we don't
even care about like one of the
externalities would be
i don't know enough about your personal
life if you're married or have kids but
one day you'll have kids and maybe
grandkids what are your grandkids going
to use for energy
so is that an externality that we should
include in our price what we've done is
we've conflated
the cost the price and the value
the cost is
you know the externalities and
and how much it costs us to pull it up
out of the ground the price is what our
economic system ascribes to it and the
value
is what it really can do for us
this stuff is like super magical pixie
dust indistinguishable from magic on
human time scales
and i don't know what price it would be
but
an order of magnitude 10 times a hundred
times more than it is today for what it
can accomplish for us
you can put some of this stuff
in a three thousand pound vehicle
and drive
hundreds of miles
for
twenty bucks
so imagine
you and your weightlifting buddies
filling up your car and driving to the
hill country in texas
and until your car runs out of gas and
then pushing that car back to austin
it would take
weeks if not months if you could do it
at all
and we just take that for granted
because we can so
but here's the thing i i one of my
projects is something called untax
where we're working with imperial
college in london and
people in the u.s government
looking at how we might tax
non-renewable inputs to our economy
like oil but not only oil
and remove the tax on humans so 95 of
our taxes right now are on humans and
corporations so if all that was removed
and if you made 50 grand a year you get
to keep 50 grand
but these things would be a lot more
costly
and
things that require a lot of resources
would be more costly but that would do
two things one it would it would make
a lot of things more expensive so our
innovation
would be more aligned with a
biophysically constrained future that i
expect and number two we would conserve
people would say i'm not going to spend
my money on that that doesn't really
make me happy
but it's so difficult to add any tax to
our system because people don't want to
give up their comfort
at all right so it's it's hard to add a
tax to our system even though there is
one there even if you were to let go of
it i remember this example from rory
sutherland where he was talking about
how they were trying to encourage people
in their 20s who had full-time jobs to
increase their pension contributions and
what they were saying is look this is
how much money you would make over time
this is why you should give us uh five
percent instead of two percent or
whatever and the the compliance rate was
just nothing no one wanted to do it
however they came up with an idea that
when people got a raise
an increased percentage of the increased
money that they were about to get paid
on their salary would be put across to
one side on their pension so people are
prepared to give away
portions of money that they haven't yet
got or haven't yet gotten used to and
this is just anchoring bias right it's
all it is anchoring bias but
when what you're saying here is people
have gotten used to paying a particular
amount for their
their iphone or their internet usage or
their air conditioning or whatever and
even if you were to give them all of
their money back
from the tax or the corp tax on
businesses or the v80 or whatever uh
they would still because of anchoring
bias the pain of the new cost would be
seen as more difficult to deal with than
the pleasure taken from the lack of
attacks
and and there's a lot of
neuroscience explanations for that i
know you know a lot about cognitive
biases one of them is loss aversion
which is if you start with ten thousand
dollars and you get a one thousand
windfall and they measure your brain
scan and you get a little bit of
dopamine and and serotonin and happiness
and then you go from eleven thousand
down to ten thousand
you feel your negative feeling is much
stronger than your positive feeling from
going up and that's what i'm afraid is
going to happen to our society which is
why we need to have individuals
recognize you know what we're really not
going to prepare ahead of time for this
as a society but as a community as a
family as an individual
i can recognize this and start to value
energy services and start to
change the things that give me meaning
and happiness away from energy intensive
activities and if you have enough of
those little rocks in the river around
the country then that acts as a buffer
to when we start down this uh lower
energy and material sort of cultural
transition
what ways could you be wrong about this
i've asked myself that i've been doing
this for 20 years chris and three or
four times i've started over like
start from scratch and
look at
who we are as biological beings
look at the relationship between energy
and technology the relationship between
energy and money
i think if you squint and look at the
future i don't think i'm wrong about the
general direction
the specifics i could be wrong if we
invent some new energy technology that
adds to our productivity and allows us
to grow for a while longer but if that
happens i won't be wrong about the
pending six mass extinction or the ocean
issues or the climate change because
those would get worse
i could be wrong if they do miraculously
find a way to turn the
kerogen which is basically oil shale
rock under the green river basin which
there are trillions
of of barrels of
technical recovery resources there but
it takes almost as more energy to
process that into oil than the oil that
we would get
so it's really not
viable i wrote my phd thesis on
something called net energy which is
measuring the cost of things in energy
terms instead of in dollar terms
so there's a lot of these things that
you look at that on the surface look
like solutions because they create
energy but if you look at a wide
boundary like
what are all the energy materials that
were required to to produce that then
the benefit to society looks less
i could be wrong if if people
suddenly change their behavior and
willingly accept
uh
less material throughput and vote to
keep carbon in the ground i don't think
i'm going to be wrong about that
i could be wrong
if nuclear fusion actually delivers and
this has always been the energy of the
future and there's a lot of private
companies investing in nuclear fusion
which is basically trying to recreate
the dynamics of the hydrogen and helium
cycle on the sun
in a factory in a chamber and
that would extend the runway but the
fundamental problem here isn't climate
change and it isn't energy depletion
it's a social animal that is a
population now of eight billion of us
that are self-organizing
as families as small businesses as
corporations as nation states to
optimize profits the profits are
directly linked to energy the energy is
directly linked 85
to fossil energy which is finite and the
whole thing is creating waste
so until we change that system i don't
think i'll be wrong about the general
direction of the story i've told you are
you worried about population collapse
i'm not worried about it per se
first of all a lot of people have very
strong opinions about population
my first answer when asked about
population is we have two population
problems eight billion humans is not
sustainable for the long run but we also
have a population of things because a
lot of those humans have three cars and
a refrigerator and a bunch of air
conditioners and other things so
every year we're adding 80 million more
humans to the planet net after births
and deaths 80 million
and every year we're adding a hundred
million three thousand pound vehicles to
the planet
which use energy and materials and
lithium and cobalt and asphalt and all
that so
my own opinion is the human population
will continue to grow the next 20 or 30
years will probably reach 9 billion
maybe 10 billion
but that the average person will be
poorer to considerably poorer materially
during that time
um i pretty much disagree with elon musk
that thinks our
decline in population is um is our clear
and present danger
because he's thinking about that from a
labor perspective but what i'm worried
about is the population of inanimate
humans added to our system the 500
billion workers are going to be retiring
in the not too distant future
so
yes population
is an issue because
we need
diapers and toys and
schools and pension funds and all these
things to continue to prop up our
current system
um but i i don't think population is in
my top five worries uh for the next
decade
yeah for the next decade i would agree i
think
looking at it
more long term
i wonder whether a potential solution to
the energy scarcity that we're facing is
going to perhaps be an ever
uh
more elderly
set of countries across the planet
because if you don't if you've got them
under replacement rate
you're going to need to make more
inanimate objects per human
in order to continue with the current
level of energy usage so if we end up if
if you know the if jordan peterson's
right and he thinks that we peak at nine
billion and then we slowly decline down
to whatever sustainable rate it is that
we end up with where everybody almost
everybody's african um because they're
currently the only places that are above
replacement
if that is the case
would that not be a potential solution
would population collapse oddly not
actually be
something that would be an energy
scarcity solution
yeah we're going to have to reduce the
amount that we consume as a global
culture that could happen with less
people or
less consumption per person or some
combination
i just don't see that directly happening
where there's
that because the un and and jordan
peterson and others forecast of
population are energy blind they don't
they look so
standard economic thinking is that
energy is not important energy is just
one of 50 different inputs into our
system so it's the cost share of energy
if if energy costs
10
it's worth 10 of pencils or ten dollars
of energy drink or ten dollars of
cupcakes they treat them all the same
but what energy does for us is orders of
magnitude more than its cost share so if
we look at all these un
world bank
iea forecasts into the future they don't
look at the fundamental
uh dynamic between energy and money and
i know that probably sounds extreme to
you
i've got a lot of other people i could
introduce you to that are saying the
same thing and forget about my phd or my
books or the people in my network just
think about it from anyone listening to
this
can in five minutes look up on the
internet how much energy is in a barrel
of oil and then do the math on how much
we can do as a physical person and look
at the relationship between the two they
could also figure out obviously a sixth
grader can figure out that this stuff is
being regenerated at one ten millionth
the pace that we're consuming it
so this is this is a challenge this is
an issue so i don't pass the next 10 or
20 years i don't believe in those
population forecasts uh from the un etc
if this is the case if your model of
what's going on and what is to come
is accurate
why is it that
i'm not hearing this be shouted from the
rooftops
because we're being anesthetized
not purposefully but there's a
homeostasis kind of like one of those
gyroscopes you hold in your hand and you
try to move it and it stays the same
we are papering over these problems with
central bank largesse with gargantuan
quantitative easing and too big to fail
guarantees and artificial low interest
rates and things to stabilize the system
and all those things also
send capital to the oil drillers etc so
the reason that we
aren't hearing this story is the energy
decline
hasn't really started yet it's just
beginning the united states i would
argue that the world hit its maximum in
oil extraction at the end of 2018.
it's possible we might grow a little bit
more in the next year or two but i think
2018 was the top we're not going to
really notice that until 10 years after
that happened
so as long as you can get energy at the
pump
as long as you can pay your utility
bills and turn on all your stuff as long
as you can still go to the bank and get
a loan
these things seem like chicken little
but i think people in europe today the
head of the iea fatih beral
said that europe has to immediately cut
their energy use by 15 or they're going
to have a disastrous winter
so that's some real stuff that's coming
down the pike i mean they're now turning
off the traffic lights in in berlin at
after 2 a.m in the morning they're
recommending that people only shower uh
once a week and they're changing their
grocery habits and all kinds of little
things like that
that i would hope that we would have a
plan for and also
people
already being mentally flexible that
they don't need all these things
um in in the future and i know it's a
long shot i know
you know
i'm we had dinner together we had some
laughs i'm i'm a funny guy if i wasn't
aware of all this stuff i would rather
be like a farmer or
a stand-up comic or something different
than this i just recognize
what's happening and i want to start a
conversation about people living
differently i don't enjoy
telling this story and i'm i'm quite
aware that it's kind of a buzz kill
people want to know
dating advice or how to be more fit or
how to have more mental clarity and this
stuff is the perfect storm for the human
brain to ignore to deny
it's complex
it's abstract it's in the future no one
famous is saying these things there are
no immediate solutions let me go switch
the channel
um
i don't know if that answered your
question
dude i'm so impressed with how lucid you
are around this stuff with being able to
take what is your right an unbelievably
multifaceted very very complex situation
and put it out so that
everybody can understand it's very very
impressive
going back to the current conversation
culturally and socially
are you frustrated with the fact that so
much
energy uh in terms of mental expenditure
and awareness and detention and focus
is on
environment and the green movement at
the moment
and yet it seems like the primary focus
of this
is firstly turning a lot of people off
to arguments that may have more
salience in one way or another
and also that it's kind of
pointing the finger at the wrong thing
everybody's concerned about whether
coral reefs are dying which is not
nothing right but it's not
the energy requirements of eight billion
humans being chopped in half within the
next few decades
first of all i don't chopped in half
might be too much but chopped down by a
third is is feasible i would think um
yeah this this gets to identity it gets
to ethics it gets to personal
uh
you know meaning um so just to be clear
i care most about the natural world and
we are
at the early stages of a six mass
extinction
the number of species that we've lost
isn't that many but the populations of
animals are down by 70 percent animal
efficient bird populations are down by
70 since i was born why so
why because of over encroachment of
human
uh development because of pesticides
because of overfishing because of over
harvesting partially due to climate
change there's a lot of reasons
uh including insects are down by 40
during that time and declining at over 1
percent a year so these are the things
at the end of the day and my deathbed
that i care the most about is the
millions of other species that we care
the share the planet with and the future
for future humans and other species
climate change is a big part of that i
think climate is over exaggerated at
times
but the truth is it is the granddaddy of
all risks during our lifetimes
but i think climate is a symptom of
these other issues and so i don't think
look there was a survey by the new york
times earlier this week that asked what
is
what are the things that you were number
one concerned about one percent of
americans said climate change three
percent of democrats by far like 23 or
so
was
inflation or the economy
so i do care deeply about the
environment but i think the larger issue
that more people are not talking about
is how we are going to
economically transition to a lower
energy and material throughput society
in the coming decades because all of our
cultural plans our institution our
government plans are expecting more in
the future
and not only are they expecting more but
the emotional
clues that we're getting
from
the stimulus package and from the
stipends and the artificial
management of the financial system all
give us this complacency that these
things can't happen
but i expect they they will happen and
something like the 1930s
is going to happen again to our country
so having said that i deeply care about
the environment i'm trying to
protect the environment by protecting
the human
social contract while all this happens
if that makes sense
what would you do or what what would you
advise
people to do we don't have a god's eye
perspective where we can coordinate the
entire world there is a tragedy of the
commons every time that somebody tells
me that i'm supposed to turn off my
lights earlier in the night time and
switch to expensive but more lower
energy consuming bulbs i always think
about all of the unused hotel rooms in
hotels that have got air conditioning
blasting all the time and it makes me
resentful um
what would you say to people what do you
say to people when it comes to preparing
themselves let's say that this does end
up coming down the pike what can people
do right now
psychologically
to and in terms of life strategy in
terms of energy usage that will not only
make the future better for everybody
else but also for themselves too
first of all you have to change how you
think about
your time on the planet there's no
uh
one-size-fits-all answer to your
question
there are immediate things we can do
intermediate and long-term things there
are things that we can do globally
nationally at a community at an
individual level what you're asking me
now is on the individual level kind of
in the near term and i think the first
thing is is recognition of
energy awareness oh my god i just look
around your house in your daily life
just one day of your life
and just notice how ubiquitous energy is
then you start to
change your definition of your net worth
more aligned with your self-worth
and i think we're going to have a major
mental health crisis in this country in
the coming decades
because people aren't really coping
already and some of your guests have
have talked about that
i think social capital is
we need to
stop measuring our success with how much
money we have and start widening the
definition to natural capital social
capital human capital
and about the biggest asset a human
being could have is friends
and a social network where you can
process these things i have a lot of
psychiatrists and psychologists in my
network who are friends and they say
that when you are when you're struggling
with the problem if you talk to another
human being about it even if you can't
find a solution you the process of
talking the way that you and i are
talking now
reduces cortisol which is a stress
hormone it boosts your helper t cells
which are good for the immune system
and the irony is chris that we are so
rich as a culture
that we can sit in our houses and order
stuff from those little brown trucks
that deliver it right to our house we're
so rich
that we don't need human interaction and
we're going to need human interaction
again and so one of the core things i
would say to people is to start
replacing finance start recognizing that
financial capital is a marker for real
capital
and as far as
turning your lights off uh versus
the hotels that leave everything on
i think
you have to
develop your own practices that are just
like brushing your teeth or flossing
that are just kind of hygienic and makes
sense for you
just turning the lights off when you
leave a room that makes sense it saves
me a little bit of money and it's the
right thing to do
but i tell my students
the time is now
not to minimize our impact on the planet
but to maximize it
so if you like hamburgers and you don't
want to drive an electric vehicle or get
solar panels
do what you have to do
and consume what you feel
appropriate in consuming
but make a difference at a larger scale
on our cultural
transition ahead
for instance i could live in a little
shack on my back 40 not using a lot of
energy and not traveling at all and i
would be
effectively 1 8 billionth of the problem
i would be solving 1 8 billionth of the
problem a little bit better
having said that i have all this
complicated equipment that i'm able to
broadcast with you and i met you in
austin because i took a flight there i'm
trying to be effective at larger scales
and if everyone did that and change the
cultural conversation away from
conspicuous consumption of stuff as our
cultural scorecard towards some more
holistic
meaning
uh joy interconnecting with the natural
world real human relationships
you know then then i think we're we're
on a better path
the first time i heard you talk about
that about changing the cultural
scorecard uh socially uh i just thought
it's going to be very difficult to do
that because i'm a person who's lived
his entire life in nightclubs so
conspicuous consumption of big bottles
of vodka is something i mean
familiar with
uh and i was like i don't really
understand until you get older until you
get older yeah and then you do something
else um
i wasn't sure i it didn't it didn't
convince me but then i went back to a
conversation that i had with a guy
called will store that wrote the status
game so he did a ton of research
anthropology he went and um i think he
might have even visited some basically
sort of uncontacted or at least did some
observation stuff on uncontacted tribes
you told me this story about a
this particular tribe
where
men compete for status on the size of
the yams that they can grow and these
men end up growing these absolutely
monstrous things right and it takes a
wheelbarrow and six people to move it
and then they come in and it's the man
that has the biggest yam and
although that's funny and kind of
ridiculous and we look at it and go oh
look how silly that is objectively
there's not much that is more silly
about that than the person that has the
ferrari the only difference is that the
ferrari like functionally has a little
bit more lifespan and there's like
things you can do with the ferrari
dude i i've spent a lot of time and
written a lot on this i can send you
some articles humans are status seeking
creatures biology you know a peacock
has that ornate feathers at three
fitness hits one they're more uh energy
materials have to go to create the tail
number two is it's more conspicuous to
predators and number three if a predator
sees you
it's less likely that you'll get away
all three of those negative fitness hits
are evolutionarily natural selection
sexually selected for by the female p
hen preferring that
so humans before the agricultural
revolution we are biological creatures
too we're midway between a tournament
and a pair bonding species which is why
men are on average six inches taller
than women world over there are plenty
of women that are taller than plenty of
men but physiologically we have this
history
and status was always very important
consumption was egalitarian for most of
our history but how we competed back in
the day meaning 50 000 years ago
was by kindness or hunting ability or
storytelling ability yams it was yams
well yams would be one example but the
point is that we do compete and the
potlatch indians in northwest washington
they would compete by throwing the most
lavish ceremony and party to give away
the wealth of the chief to the neighbors
and however much they could give away
was the signal of how much status they
would have so the key is you're
absolutely right right now we're
competing for
bank accounts and shopping centers and
pecuniary wealth and expensive watches
and night plumbing or whatever
but if our society suddenly
the women preferred the best gardeners
that grew the largest tomatoes
the rodal books at amazon and barnes
nobody will be sold out in a weekend
so yes how we get our status
and right now a lot of us get it on
facebook and instagram likes and it's
even a fake status it's it's a super
normal stimuli version of the status
but we're not going to stop comparing
ourselves to others full stop we are not
going to do that we can change how we
compare ourselves to others in ways that
end up using less energy and materials
and i think there's zillions of ways for
pilots and examples of young people and
young people already my students a lot
of them don't even have driver's
licenses because they they don't want to
buy a car
not because they're doing the right
thing for the planet but the economic
circumstances are they can't afford it
and so i think this is going to evolve
and what do
we
what will be the things that are really
cool culturally
i want to be like them
well in your in my lifetime that's the
ferrari and the fancy house and the
corporate jet or whatever
that's going to change because it's
going to have to change and i think we
can all play a role in what that might
look like i don't know what it looks
like but you could adapt it to something
which not only continues to you you're
right you can't get rid of the fact that
status status seeking is is going to be
something that we do
but you can align that which you get
status from with that which has positive
externalities which may not only be good
for you but good for everybody else as
well dude i love it i love it i you
reckoned that this was going to take
four hours for you to explain everything
and you've managed to do it in an hour
and 13 minutes so i i really appreciate
you i really appreciate the work i think
that it's a fascinating area of
discussion i think for me as somebody
that's kind of because i've been into
x-risk for so long and
the climate change conversation in terms
of how it's typically presented to me is
just so
not seductive i find it annoying i find
it overblown i feel like everyone should
be talking about nanotechnology or
bioweapons or whatever it might be
and yet
you've given me
a way to think about energy
it is to do with climate and ecology and
stuff like that too uh where it
it justifies me putting that right at
the front of of my mind i think the
work's great man so congratulations on
your on your thinking and being able to
communicate it so lucidly
well i've spent 20 years connecting this
story have you watched my 30-minute
animated movie that i just made okay so
that that tells the story um
i'm still learning chris and and one
thing that you told me at dinner with
your large plate of food that i recall
is you said everyone eventually
converges on the biggest problem
and i do think this decade we will
converge on on this problem which is
how do we use less energy materials to
get the same or more or different
uh experiences that are that are more
sustainable and i think that's that will
be the conversation of our of our time
nate higgins ladies and gentlemen if
people want to check out the animated
video that you spoke about and all of
the other stuff that you do why would
you send them
uh they can go to
thegreatsimplification.com or the nate
higgins youtube channel and there i have
a podcast and there's lots of videos etc
nate i appreciate you thank you for
today
thanks chris what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
you